First, Mark, it's a pleasure to be here today.
I'd like to introduce my colleague, Cheryl Hiddleston,
who will tell you a little bit about what she does.
Hi. I'm Cheryl Hiddleston,
I have been a nurse for 33 years.
For 26 of those,
I've been in critical care,
and I currently run the Emory eICU program.
And my name is Tim Buckman.
I have the privilege being the founding director of Emory's Critical Care Center.
I'm the Medical Director of Emory's eICU program.
Perhaps, we ought to tell you a little bit about what an ICU is and what an eICU is.
That would be great.
You know, we all enjoy our health but at some point,
we all will face serious health problems.
And when our vital organs, heart, lungs, liver,
kidneys become compromised they can fail to the point where our lives are threatened.
That's where the ICU comes in.
Patients are admitted to intensive care units,
in order to stabilize their vital functions,
set the stage for healing and allow them to improve.
Now traditionally that's been all at the bedside, critical care nurses,
critical care physicians,
other allied health professionals working to stabilize the patient at the elbow.
But in the era of long distance telecommunication,
a new option has evolved. Cheryl, tell them about eICU.
The eICU is a program that provides
remote surveillance monitoring of patients in the ICUs at different hospitals.
We have cameras, monitors, and mics,
and speakers in each patient room that allows our team,
which is located remotely in
basically an office building to have bidirectional communication with the staff,
the family, and the patient who are in the ICUs.
With the monitoring that we do,
the system pulls different data from
the bedside monitor and
the electronic medical record and has different algorithms built in it,
and it allows us to catch when
patients are veering off trajectory into the wrong direction.
So we can call the staff at the bedside and help intervene.
Now it's a lot of data.
We have the same big data problem, the four Vs, the velocity, variety, veracity,
value that everyone has in the big data space.
The difference is we have to find problems and fix them right now.
Because if we don't deliver the right care right now for every patient every time,
the patient is going to suffer.
Let's talk about an example,
that is a prominent one in critical care.
We all have kidneys.
They allow us to not only get rid of excess water
but excess toxins and without good kidney function,
those toxins build up,
the various balance of electrolytes and fluids in the body goes awry.
And with total kidney failure, people can die.
So we have to find that problem and fix it right away.
One of the conventional measures
of kidney function is actually taken from the bloodstream,
a chemical called creatinine.
Creatinine is produced as a product of
normal metabolism by muscles and then excreted by the kidneys.
When the kidneys fail to function well, creatinine builds up.
And when the kidneys resume their function,
creatinine decreases in concentration in the bloodstream.
Now there are two or three problems.
The first is that creatinine isn't sampled continuously,
it isn't even sampled regularly, it's sampled irregularly.
So physicians at best have
an irregular time series from which to
try to reason whether the kidney function is getting better,
getting worse, or staying the same.
And if you look at the visualization on the left is conventional picture of creatinine,
a plot of creatinine measurements versus time.
And what you'll see is that creatinine rises when
kidneys fail in this sense when kidneys recover function.
But we needed a way to look more deeply into the data to discover whether there might be
hidden information in the time series that would allow us to
recognize even earlier first the kidney function is getting worse,
and even more importantly,
the kidney function is recovering.
Why do we want to know the kidney function is recovered?
We want to be able to
tell patients and families that things are getting better as soon as possible.
So we charged a team in the course with helping us develop a novel visualization.
That's shown on the right.
It's a phase diagram,
plotting the change in creatinine over time on the Y-axis
versus the concentration of creatinine on the X-axis.
And what you can see even as creatinine is rising,
there's an inflection point where the rate of change of that rise is falling.
That's our earliest signal that kidney function is
actually improving and being able to see these displays,
these phase diagrams allows us to recognize the problem earlier,
and even more importantly to recognize recovery earlier.
That matters to caregivers but it also
matters more to the patients for whom we deliver care.
I'll let Cheryl speak a bit about
the challenges we face even in
the standard clinical realm of bringing health care messages into our care environment.
As Tim said, normally for laboratory values,
they're checked intermittently, there's
no regular schedule that they're checked on necessarily.
It's done per a physician's orders and what they determine needs to be done.
So we have a database for all of the patients we provide care for and in order to
get more real-time access to that information and
have the data pushed out to us rather than having to wait for it to come in the system,
having someone look at it.
That's what we discussed with the students.
Now trying to get access to that database for
them was kind of a hurdle because it's patient information that's involved.
So we had to get compliance involved,
we had to get the IS resources involved to
make sure that the Georgia Tech students had access to the data,
so they could build the application.
So we could actually develop the tools.
Now what's interesting of course is that there are
international standards around healthcare messaging, so-called HL7 standard.
And we use that standard in our communications with the hospitals we serve.
The problem is that HL7 messaging has evolved
and Version 1 was primitive and Version 2 was manageable, Version 3, well,
it became seriously bloated,
often 60 pages of data just to report the single laboratory value.
And quite candidly, that's more than
current systems are able to manage efficiently and effectively in real-time.
Fortunately, the communities who
develop these standards recognized that they'd created a problem and said,
we have to do it faster.
We actually have to get Fast Healthcare Interoperability Resources up and running.
FHIR, that's what FHIR is all about.
And what our students have done,
they've helped us to take
our existing databases into which all the data are falling and said,
we can simplify not the incoming messages
because those are fixed by standards but outgoing messages.
We can help clinicians access those data faster and better by FHIR enabling the database.
And that really is a major event because data that's not available in
the moment is data that is
the delayed and decisions that are delayed and ultimately the care is delayed.
We recognize that every human being
is different but they get sick in a fairly patterned fashion.
So our job is to recognize the patterns.
You would think this would be easy but recognize that every human being has
12 different body systems add the dimension of
time and we have a 13-dimensional problem with sparse data.
So picking up the patterns is tough.
We have a couple of things we can do though.
We can have machines recognize and pick out the patterns and our responses.
In fact, that's going to be much of the future of medicine,
to follow patterns and provide the responses that seem to be most common.
It's especially helpful in our environment because our patients are so complex
and threading down to the abstraction that matters,
the getting sick and what we can do to help
people get well is an important part of what we do.
What's going to happen in the future?
We think that there're couple of steps.
The first is a form of crowdsourcing.
We will ask our clinicians and ask the machines behind our clinicians to
keep track of what data patterns are clinically meaningful and which are not.
Second, we'll go into the data and begin to cull out the universal responses.
We'll find two or three responses to every problem.
But what we can do further and we can use the data
going forward to determine which of
the responses to the problem, actually leads to the better outcome.
This is emerging of knowledge based care.
Things have come from evidence-based medicine and code, things that have come,
this is emerging of knowledge based care,
things that have come from evidence data.
This is emerging of knowledge based care,
knowledge that's encoded in algorithms and decision trees with database care,
recognizing the 1,000 or 10,000,
or 100,000 nearest neighbors and
understanding what care has been provided and understanding the outcomes of those cared.
The eICU is a perfect training ground
for this because instead of asking clinicians at the bedside,
who are very busy taking care of patients,
"Oh, is this appropriate?"
"Is this an actionable item?"
It pulls them away from patient care.
So in the eICU, you have nurses,
who are trained in detecting when there's an anomaly and there's something different.
So it's a perfect area to try and build this sort of knowledge.
If we can improve our detection of anomalies,
improve our understanding of the options available to us,
and improve our understanding of the outcomes of those options.
We're going to get better outcomes for all of our patients.